Every since my first online Java program, back in 1997, I've been excited by
the potential of the Internet to teach 3D graphics. Interactive 3D graphics,
with speed and quality equal to that seen in AAA title games and high-end CAD
packages, is now possible on the web. I'm also thrilled that we can now share
programs in a straightforward way. No installs, no compilation, and anyone can
look at the code being run. Udacity's motto is Learn, Think, Do. I find that
perfect for interactive rendering. You don't need to buy a DNA sequencer or
array of radio telescopes. You have everything you need at hand.
Experimentation is easy and quick with 3js. The only danger is the risk of
staying up till 4 AM saying, what if I twiddle with this parameter. I ran
across a great quote from Confucius while making this course. Every truth has
four corners. As a teacher, I can give you one, but you must provide the other
three. This suits my view of computer graphics. You can be given a firm
foundation, but you're the one who really needs to pursue knowledge and learn
by doing. Confucius probably meant something different. Don't forget you have a
giant reference library at your fingertips. Much of what I found for these
lessons consisted of me typing in 3JS collision detection and seeing what the
search engine popped up. Developing any sort of interactive 3-D graphics
program was out of reach of almost everyone 20 years ago because back then
graphics accelerators cost the price of a luxury car. Now they're the price of
a large pizza. Even up until a few years ago, creating a 3-D application
involved compilers and downloads and installs and once you were done, it would
usually work on only one operating system. If you ran someone else's glorious
demo, you were usually less Scratching your head. How do they do it? The fact
is you can now make a wonderful 3D interactive that anyone with a browser can
access with just a click and can read the code that created it with just a few
more. How amazing is that? There's so much you can do, figure out what someone
else's code does, write your own programs, write your own libraries. Even
contribute to 3JS itself, and if you do, document it. Go off and do great
things, and whatever you do, send me the link.